hey this is Damon with wired and this is
the lit motors Siwon
if you're anything like me you value
your life which is probably one of the
reasons you don't own a motorcycle
that said though 80% of the population
drives one car with one person into work
every day
that means we've got clogged roads we've
got a ton of other issues we have to
deal with on a regular basis and that's
where this comes in this is the c1 from
San Francisco California based lit
motors it is a fully electric motorcycle
but it's fully enclosed and the
production model is gonna have airbags &
infotainment and all that and eventually
it's gonna be an all-wheel-drive bike so
that's not the cool part though the cool
part is there's two gyros mounted
beneath the passenger and driver and
that allows the c1 to stay upright no
matter what the condition is so you can
literally push on it with a weight of
about a baby elephant and it'll stay
bolt upright you can go through corners
relatively quickly and there's no worry
about it capsizing or toppling over if
another vehicle hits it it can stay
upright the entire time so this is the
first prototype of the c1 it's kind of a
rolling proof of concept the lab for
them to work on as they work on the
production model now when it goes on
sale in 2014 it'll have a top speed of
120 miles per hour
a range of over 200 miles and more
importantly it'll be about $24,000 if
they hit the market right within two
years of that it'll be down to sixteen
thousand dollars it has the potential of
revolutionized the way we get around